[Music]
hey I'm Adam I come from a jazz and rock
background
I'm nari I come from a classical piano
background and I'm LA and I come from a
gospel and hip-hop R&B background and
we're gonna chat about some of our
thoughts surrounding learning by ear
versus learning with sheet music and
then we're gonna jam and put all this to
test it's gonna be do yes
[Music]
before I started lessons I just really
liked the keyboard and then I copied
what my teacher was doing but can only
keep that up to a certain point didn't
if you don't know how to read you're out
of luck I would play to records in my
basement playing tune Yonsei concert
watching the DVDs that's how I learned
I'm saying arranging she watching is
just as important as practice an
employee
[Music]
I started by learning piano and then I
had learned how to play bass because
there was a band starting and they just
needed a bass player and I promptly
stopped playing piano and I said like
this is the cool thing yeah I'm gonna
learn
[Music]
yeah this perfect I've never jammed like
this before
well this is such a relief because we've
always been you know communicating the
video no talk and everything but this
person making music together playing
first time you guys playing it together
the same time yeah in in gospel music as
far as like energy is concerned like the
level one is like the basic group level
two is the bridge it's the next level
energy level three is the vamp that's
what all the craziness happens all the
extra chords hits lines all that level
three and you gotta end on level three
[Music]
one thing I realize about you know in
this setting is like we have to be
sensitive and vulnerable sometimes this
sort of situation is hard because you're
so used to wanting music to be good or
right and this exercise is much more
about opening up
[Music]
it does take a while to get into that
mindset especially if you've never done
it before which is crazy than I read
that this was your first time doing it
yeah I'm used to reading cues in a
different way in classical music there's
usually a designated person you know in
a string quartet it'll be the first
violinist and everyone will pay
attention to them one skill that I
learned so just in church
that isn't taught in school is the skill
of lip-reading being able to play while
you're still reading and understanding
and then process that information and
translate it over to your instrument
[Music]
that helps level-1 level-2 yeah I played
a gig with the Minnesota Orchestra so
that at this church we joined this
gospel concert thing and I could not
watch the conductor for my world yeah
this this is the ictus as soon as I get
down there that's when the note should
come out so it's like classic always
there's apparently a good reason for
that
it's for the conductor to Telegraph what
it's supposed to be made less especially
because every conductor is different yes
some are very ahead of the beat and some
work very exactly so it's like once you
learn the language of following a
conductor you have to fine-tune the
language to the specific conductor that
you're okay that's not really hard to do
I had to watch the violinist and to
watch the their bows for the rhythm I
was close to them I didn't know what
else to pay attention to
[Music]
[Music]
to it to me and charges like are we
going to the next park
that's all I mean but that to me is
amazing how can you follow all those
choose know what's going on based on the
context and retain all of that
information musically and be able to
improvise over it
a nari find something cool of that you
wrote your thing find a cool chunk I
[Music]
tell my students the more you move your
body the better your time will be yeah
[Music]
for the longest time I didn't get the
music in my body that's kind of where I
struggle I visualize lines or shapes
do you guys visualize anything in your
heads while you're playing that can look
at a lot of different kinds of sheet me
as it can be able to hear it in my head
which I think it's one of the
interesting things about reading music
versus not reading music I plan I try to
like pretend like I'm already on the
stage I'm sorry for you that would be
visualizing 5,000 people like so like
shawl killing why this applies Alfie to
in a pop in a prom dress okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
we'd like to thank Adam for jamming with
us and also if you haven't already
please check out his new video
discussing whether or not playing to a
backing track is considered cheating
[Music]